Oh somebody help
hey leave him alone it's a tough world
out there and it's getting tougher all
the time and the world is not going to
change
hello it's you that has to change
something amazing happened you have to
see what I found there's something
written on the guard put it into google
translate it means sort of Arthur what
if it's the sword in the stone there are
four days until the solar eclipse when
Morgana will enter the world of the
living and I was pushed up that's
ridiculous I'm 12
so Nolan was pushed below that you look
for 16
an ingenious alias in order to monitor
incognito you will need to assemble a
team of Knights bosses noise gathered a
round table so that they were all equal
and look quit bonus lift up the flaps
see oh my god you're such a nerd
this is this me the five of us won't son
a chance northern we need to raise an
army
how are you milli ating this is instead
of lessers today
[Applause]
ever happen
why did you drive Mario Kart love don't
freak out okay Lady of the lake please
return Excalibur
[Music]
you